so er I want to ask you a question since
I've known you for 20 years almost okay
you and me both share a love for
immersive experiences right and and by
definition this means we like to
submerge and lose ourselves in
particular contexts and by definition to
lose oneself is to enter a state of
ecstasy ecstatic the etymology of the
word ex tasses means to go beyond
oneself to be beside oneself and this
okay was also sort of reformulated in
the words of Jerry Garcia Jerry Garcia
said to get really high is to forget
yourself but to forget yourself is to
see everything else so you know nothing
is lost only a lot is gained this
experience is where we find relief from
the burden of selfhood the terrible
tyrant the overactive ego is therapeutic
so explain to me whether it's the
skydiver or the elite sports athlete or
the adrenaline junkie or the movie buff
that we find such relief from losing
ourselves in other words like you even
say when you go snowboarding and you get
like super high and you're snowboarding
on the mountain and you're in the moment
and beauty of nature is racing past your
face like how why is that so therapeutic
why is that so cleansing why is losing
ourselves so detoxifying you know why
wow I mean you have to become one with
something yes you know I mean so in the
snowboarder you become one with the
mountain the guy become one with the
wave you have to become one with
something okay and to achieve that you
really have to forget yourself no that's
what you need to do Keeley right now
hitting the nail on the head he just
listened to my rhapsodizing on why I
feel so good too
lose ourselves yet why we resisted right
we cling to ourselves we're terrified of
surrendering Newton none of us is really
volunteering when it comes to letting go
we're kicking and screaming into these
blissful mind body states beyond the
self and we know that all the good [ __ ]
happens when we lose ourselves because
when we lose ourselves we become one
with everything
Terence Mckenna said you become what you
behold absolute unmixed attention is a
form of prayer William James said your
experience is what you attend to but
here's the thing you can't attend to
anything out there if you're busy
attending to yourself this is when the
self and neurosis becomes oppressive the
burdens of being right the burdens of
mortality the tyranny of time the
responsibility survival of the fittest
the Darwinian imposition upon our
freedom to survive when we go beyond the
self during these recreational States
during these spiritual states during
these contemplative states that freedom
from self that relief for himself vastly
transforms how we see ourselves and
frame ourselves during these moments
that Tim duty
we recontextualize the self as a
marvelous conduit in a timeless whole
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebula and back again so
some people lose themselves and have
cosmic moments other people lose
themselves and become one with the wave
people call this Nirvana that jazz
musicians lose themselves and rhapsodize
through a tumbling thicket of melodies
and free association only and rings with
their jazz form and we marvel with
gasped in astonishment sometimes
sometimes we actually witness slices and
splices of divinity you know
human beings attain things when they're
not there to conspire against themselves
why is it that when we lose ourselves
not only do we become one with
everything not only do we have cosmic
moments not only do we have realizations
but performance also sometimes goes up
I'm more clever when I let go my work is
better my connection with you is deeper
my empathy is brighter because I truly
believe that when you two become one
with something you have to not think
about the next move hmm okay jazz yeah
he doesn't think he doesn't read from
the from the book of Noemi and you see
already what's gonna be the next note -
he's thinking about it so what do you
say improvise he improvise but you think
that improvisation is tapping to an
inner knowing because you not think
about the next move it just flows and
that was that flow metaphysical when you
are one with everything and performance
goes up and you lose your sense of self
and you're free from the tyranny of time
and you have a lateral thinking increase
so you see more patterns you get more
information your brain is flooded with
dopamine and you get out of your own way
I mean it's like it's like the movie
Black Swan when the choreographer tells
Natalie Portman the only thing standing
in your way is you
which is not to say that contemplative
or that practice and discipline and
control don't have their place right the
White Swan is precision is discipline is
practice its commitment that's the White
Swan but then the Black Swan the last
one surrenders the Black Swan let's go
the Black Swan forgets herself surprises
herself experiences transcendence of
herself
it's whoo yeah we need both but we can't
have one without the other because if we
do if we're all control clinging to
ourselves desperately then we're trapped
in a prison of our own making
but if we let go of the reins completely
and are completely undisciplined in our
freedom and our meanderings well then
we'll get torn apart by the sea of chaos
we won't be cresting that wave will be
wipe outing and maybe not even being
able to come up for air so balance I
think for me for example I'm hyper
vigilant I'm highly controlling and
neurotic and I struggle more with
learning to let go and learning to
surrender this has been a challenge for
me as you know I know it's harder for
you to let go yeah but I'm getting
better you're gonna you will until the
precise environment is important because
for you it's sacred that's what makes it
different between you and other people
but for you you've made it the sacred
moment yeah yeah it's like it's kind of
like somebody that only gets naked with
their intimate partner a little bit like
that like me let it go be shutting off
my monkey mind is like having really
intimate sex with my girlfriend it's
like saying only with her do you get to
see me naked do you get to see me when
I'm not there
Wow anyway so cultivate a practice of
letting go but also cult apply cultivate
cultivate discipline cultivate both both
muscles you know surrender let go but
then fetch water and chop wood do the
work let us know what you think in the
comments below
[Laughter]